foreign
store is live from the Sky News City
Studio
British energy Giants BP reveals record
annual profits but tweets plans to
reduce oil and gas production
my investment in sport by private equity
and Sovereign wealth funds is to carry
on booming
U.S Network's giant Cisco announced his
plans to train 10 million people in
digital skills plus Manchester unspun
the new book that Chronicles the city's
40 Years of regeneration
foreign
this is Ian King live in our business
and economic news from the Heart of the
City Welcome to viewers watching us live
today on the Sky News website mobile app
and on YouTube where we begin today with
news at BP has this morning reported a
record full year profit for 2022 of 27.7
billion US dollars that compares with an
underlying replacement cost profit which
is the industry's recognized measure of
12.8 billion dollars in 2021 but profits
at the company slowed sharply during the
final three months of last year
underlying replacement cost profit for
the quarter came in at 4.8 billion
dollars compared with 8.2 billion
dollars during the previous quarter
which BP said reflected a below average
Gas marketing and trading result and
lower oil and gas prices at a headline
level meanwhile BP reported a two and a
half billion dollar loss for the year
down from 7.6 billion dollars in 2021
reflecting non-cash write Downs incurred
with its exit from Russia BP also
announced it was rowing back on plans to
reduce its oil and gas production by
2030 from 40 percent of 2019 levels it's
now aiming for a reduction of around 25
percent or BP's chief executive Bernard
Looney has been speaking to our
colleagues at CNBC this morning during
which he addressed the taxes paid by the
company
we actually paid a record level of taxes
in 2022 the largest amount of tax we
paid in our history was paid in 2022 in
the UK for every four pounds that we
make in the North Sea we pay three
pounds now in taxes and we're pretty
much reinvesting all of the rest
or joining me this morning is Ross mold
he's investment director at AJ Bell Ross
good to see you this morning I mean I
guess if there's a blemish on these
numbers it's the it's the Q4 figures
they're a bit of a disappointment aren't
they
came in a very a very little bit light
if you're being absolutely ruthlessian
they've we've seen oil and gas prices
come down the Cardiology refer to weaker
marketing uh prices which is refining
and prices at the pump and also
increased downtime and maintenance and
it's refined it's oil refineries but
overall they are still making as we know
an awful lot of money
now the main headline I guess is that
they've trimmed these plant production
Cuts in oil and gas output I mean is
that a reflection that the strategy to
go full Pelt into Renewables is is not
quite working in so far as shareholders
go
um Mr Looney refers to the chief
executive refers in the statement to you
know the reality that we're going
through an energy crisis the energy
security has become a much greater issue
as we've had as the West has had to wean
itself off Russian oil and gas so I
think it's a it's a degree an acceptance
of that reality that supplies of
critical importance and you also have
other issues which is that story we saw
in the financial times and other
newspapers yesterday referring to all of
those renewable projects that are
waiting for connection to the grid but
can't get it and there was one project
being quoted a connection time of about
2036 so it's all very well yeah
definitely worthy to go for wind solar
hydrogen but if you then can't get the
stuff connected to the Grid or store it
it's not as helpful as it would be
otherwise so again there is a hint very
strongly that whether we like it or not
we may be more Reliant upon hydrocarbons
than we would like to be for longer than
we would like to be well absolutely I
mean BP of all the oil majors has been
far more committed to the transition to
Renewables than any of its peers at all
is this an admission though that they're
not going to enjoy this same Returns on
Capital that they would do from
traditional fossil fuel activities yeah
but they do talk they do Target very
clearly a big increase in profits from
their from their transition growth
engines as they call them TGs hydrogen
Renewables solar and so on and they are
looking for a big increase in profit
there and they are increasing their
capital investment there by eight
billion over the rest of this decade but
the company is increasing its investment
in oil and gas by eight billion over the
next decade which environmental
campaigns will Despair and investors who
look for who run strict environmental
social and government screens may not be
too pleased either but equally those
investors who will look at it just as a
matter of dollars and cents nickels and
dimes may be thinking we will again need
oil and gas for longer than we think
these aren't going to be way stranded
assets and they may actually be uh happy
to see um that investment from a purely
Financial point of view now what about
this tax issue Russ I mean Bernard
Looney addressed it uh full on there I
mean BP is paying a disproportionately
high level of taxes in the UK it seems
relative to its its Global earnings it's
not going to be enough to keep the
politicians at Bay do you think
well I mean I think that the company's
Global uh taxation Bill nearly traveled
to just under 17 billion dollars I guess
what's interesting is that one argument
against windfall taxes was that it would
deter investment and BP is kind of
Shrugged that one off today with its
increased capital investment plans in
Renewables and oil and gas so that
argument's been slightly shot down I
guess where Financial shows will be
coming at it from is they paid the
higher tax they're increasing the
dividend they're paying down their debt
they're doing share BuyBacks they're
still paying money to the Gulf of Mexico
1.3 billion dollars in the coming year
and they're able to do that without too
much difficulty at the moment and so
long as oil stays above 60 dollars a
barrel it sounds as if BP is going to
remain a cash machine for some time to
come so I'm sure the issue isn't going
away I guess BP's increase in investment
across the board May at least satisfy
some people that it is you know
continuing to make its efforts to get
towards Net Zero by 2050. and of course
the other thing is uh in the numbers
that struck me they're net debt at 21.4
billion dollars is at its lowest level
for a decade I mean that potentially
does free them up for more divis and
share Buybacks in the future I guess it
does I mean they made an acquisition
Before Christmas okay you're a buy or
mass Energy company I guess come you
know Charles May might be a little bit
wary of a big acquisition Splurge but I
think they'll be relatively
understanding on increased investors
in the double digit returns that VP is
targeting but yet overall less debt
means less risk less risk can in a
higher share price I think that's you
know to get the debt pile down so
quickly certainly during a very
difficult time for the company as well
is amazing I know there's lots of
debates over windfall taxes but this is
a company that did not go obligold
beating to the price brief negative in
2020 it helped itself it cut costs it
got investment it sold assets and it
paid down debt so it has been a big
self-help program no State help required
all right got to leave it there good to
see you this morning thank you keep well
a bit of breaking uh news to bring you
uh there is a cabinet uh reshuffle
expected today and the times is
reporting on its online editions at Cami
balanok who's the international trade
secretary is going to be uh having her
job recast into the business and trade
secretary more on that as we get it
now investment into sport by private
equity and Sovereign wealth funds is
booming with recent examples including
Society public investment fund buying
Newcastle United red bird Capital buying
AC Milan and CVC Capital taking a stake
in rugby Six Nations for that process
has some way to go according to a survey
today the latest Global Sports survey by
the business services giant PWC has
found that more than three quarters of
senior Sports Executives believe such
investment will continue to grow during
the next three to five years or joining
the now is Clive Reeves he's the global
Sports leader at PWC Clive welcome to
you what is driving this investment
activity
good morning Ian um yeah obviously a lot
of activity in the sports uh investment
space at the moment what's driving this
activity really is the um the
availability of some of the premiums
football clubs uh reported in an hour
available uh we're seeing a lot of uh us
investors moving into European football
and really I think it's around the
availability of the the assets uh these
organizations don't transact very often
I think we're looking 10 15 20 years
since some of the biggest clubs in
Europe actually exchange owners so we're
seeing a lot of opportunity now for
investors to come in
um and obviously these are scarce assets
and obviously as a result of that um
highly sought after
aren't all these investors going to get
a good return on the money they've
invested
I think when you look at any investment
in in any sector particularly in sports
and particularly in football you look at
it from a value creation perspective
obviously what are you what are you
buying in terms of the team uh the
stadium the infrastructure the global
fan base and then you're looking from a
perspective of how do I create value
from this I think some of the
organizations reported to be available
now have some of the you know the
biggest fan bases in the world uh you
know competing at the highest level
winning trophies and that I think for
any investor is a particularly uh
exciting opportunity and a lot of the
investors coming in now into support and
football we'll look at it from a how do
I grow the you know the fan base how do
I commercialize it in new ways and then
we look at things like digital and web 3
where the new opportunities May emerge
uh which allows you know to grow the
revenue of these organizations
what do you expect her to be the blind
share of investment uh directed towards
is it going to be an individual teams
and franchises like Newcastle United or
will it be an entire competitions that's
with CVC in the Six Nations
yeah it is a really interesting question
and I guess the answer is we're seeing a
spread from the survey data you know
from our Sports Executives they really
identify the premium Sports properties
would be the focus however I do think we
are seeing investments into teams as we
just discussed uh we have seen obviously
States brought into leagues such as La
Liga and Liga with CBC and we've also
seen investments into sports federations
for example volleyball more recently I
think we also are going to see some
investment into what we call emerging
Sports if we look at the US
um with pickleball or we look at Pavel
as another example some of these
emerging new sports are always also
really interesting opportunities for
investors absolutely well we've had
Andrew Andy Murray on this program
talking about his investment in paddle
um I just wonder what you think all this
heavy investment into teams and
franchises will do for international
competition I mean it's clearly affected
football and Mike Atherton wrote The
Times the other day that it feels as so
crooked is going to go the same way
yeah I think I think it's a really
interesting uh time for sport and this
is across all sports and I guess the key
to this really is the sporting calendar
and then we've seen a lot of debates in
discussion in rugby and and the article
you referred to in cricket and obviously
in football as well the volume of uh
competitions is is growing uh the stress
on the athletes obviously to participate
in all these events is also increasing
so I think it's very much around
stakeholders coming together really to
work through you know what is the sort
of optimal calendar for everybody to
have their space uh which allows you to
have the storytelling narrative which
drives the audience and the fan bases of
these Sports resulting that allows
esport to grow their revenues we're
saying gets reinvested back into the
sport to help them grow so the key
question here really is around uh you
know agreeing across stakeholders the
sporting calendar and that allows then
everyone to have their their moments to
you know show the best of their
competitions now the other really big
takeaway for me was the growth of
women's sport you see a lot more
investment coming into into that
yeah we think on the back of the the
recent success of say for example the
Euros uh with the lionesses no amazing
success uh we've seen around the world
now with the you know the IPL franchise
sale more recently uh went for 450
million uh pounds I think Plus for five
teams and so we're seeing a huge you
know growth of women's sport and
actually we think this is really a
moment in time for women's sport to
really accelerate its growth in our
survey we asked our Sports Executives
what are the key ingredients of that and
really what it came down to was the
media in particular paying a driving
force to increase the visibility of
women's sport uh to grow the fandom and
grow the reach and I think if we can do
that that allows us to attract the right
commercial partners and grow the
revenues into women's sport which then
can be reinvested back into the sport
from a participation development and
obviously into the elite level I think
if we get all that together and we get
that flywheel moving and we really
believe
um we're everyone working together this
was a really the moment in time for
women's sport to release to accelerate
and what about uh Sports rights
ownership I mean again you think there's
going to be an encroachment on the
traditional broadcasters from the likes
of Apple and Google
yeah this is a fascinating finding from
the from our survey actually in terms of
we asked the sports Executives who are
best place to to win for the rights in
the next five years and over 70 said
actually the big tech companies are sort
of going to be much more competitive
let's say and we've seen this trend in
the US you know obviously Apple uh with
the MLS deal more recently a 10-year
deal which is the first real big move
from from them you've obviously got
YouTube now with the NFL and also Amazon
you know buying rights big rights in the
US and obviously increasingly buying
rights in Europe so I think the the long
debate we've had in sport is Will big
Tech move in and I think we're
definitely now seeing signs that yes
they will the question really for us now
is what does that mean for obviously
broadcasters and also how does the
monetization model work with a big Tech
coming in will they you know change the
monetization model away from sort of
subscription based and being sort of
more monetizing they're asking other
ways so we think this is a really
exciting time for sport because they're
more interested in the rights growing
the reach growing the audience can only
be good thing for everyone involved in
sport all right cool I've got to leave
it there good to see you this morning
thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and UK house prices stopped falling
last month according to the Halifax the
UK's biggest mortgage lender says there
was no change in the average highest
price in January following declines in
each of the four previous months well
the figures are in contrast to those
published last week by Nationwide which
said prices fell in January for a fifth
consecutive month on a year-on-year
basis house price growth slowed to 1.9
percent that was down from 2.1 percent
in December and was the weakest growth
for three years well Halifax said the
biggest slowdown in annual house price
inflation had been in Wales and the West
country where it has been strongest in
recent years
the Danish Brewing giant Carlsberg
warned this morning that its profits
growth was slow this year as higher beer
prices hit consumption the world's third
largest Brewer said it expects operating
profits this year to rise by five
percent at best and warned that they
could even fall by as much as five
percent well that compares with growth
of 12 in the year just gone Carlsberg
said it would need to raise its prices
this year in the high single digits to
recover its Rising costs it also said it
expects to find a buyer for its business
in Russia where is the largest Brewer
before the summer
and the world's second largest gold
mining company this morning ruled itself
out of a bid for the world's seventh
biggest player the chief executive of
canada-based Barrett gold told Bloomberg
that the company was not looking to get
bigger just for the sake of it but his
comments came after U.S based Newmont
which is the world's biggest gold miner
made a bit of 16.9 billion dollars for
its smaller Australian rival new Crest
well the latter was once an Australian
subsidiary of Newmont but it was spun
off 33 years ago
now the beginning of the year saw the
implementation of a windfall tax on
electricity generators the electrical
generator Levy is a 45 temporary charge
on exceptional receipts generated by the
production of wholesale electricity the
idea behind it was that due to the
rising Global electricity prices UK
generators have received vastly
increased revenues for their supplies
because for structural reasons the price
of electricity is tied to the price of
natural gas but Renewables generators
for the Levee is putting their sector at
risk for joining me now is Rod Wood he's
managing director at Community wimpa Rod
welcome to you you're not disputing I
take it that you your sector is enjoying
exceptional revenues good morning no no
we're not this is a temporary a
temporary issue the price is already
cutting down dramatically as you know
gas and oil oil prices and electricity
prices are dropping down and my
understanding is that the forecast for
this this year is the 12.8 billion that
was allocated to support tumor guarantee
is actually going to be down at 1.5
billion and could be it could be less
again I think of the resolution in the
crb a br so there's a great reduction in
that so we can't don't quite see how
they can look forward in taxes over the
next five years when this problem May at
some point go away or be greatly reduced
you're claiming though that the oil and
gas sector is being treated more
favorably than your sector how can that
be the case when the North Sea taxation
rate is now 75 percent well that's a
very good point in the the the two two
issues are the first one is that uh the
the actual taxation is 75 but they are
offered a very generous tax incentive so
for every pound they invest in the North
Sea over the next five years they will
get back from UK government and from
ourselves 91 Pence as an investment
allowance if you look at the egl uh in
fact there we see the zero investment
allowance we get no investment allowance
whatsoever so they're encouraging uh the
oil companies to invest in oil and gas
and actually this incentivizing
Renewables for investing why is that
have you I mean presumably you've raised
this with government we have and they
don't seem to be they don't seem to
understand the fact that there's a
difference between the uh the investment
allowance so for the levy uh versus the
the super deduction which is what
they're talking of offering and I gather
that was all tied in with the increasing
incorporation in fact from 19 25 and I
think CBI mentioned this in the same
time they're looking to increase uh the
the super deduction uh to 130 that
hasn't happened but that only relates to
the corporation tax so the the big issue
for the egl for us is actually going to
stop investment in new Renewables new
infrastructure at a time as you know
when Joe Biden has put it together a 370
billion power package for Investments
and subsidy and support r d in the US
likewise in Europe as well 200 billion
going in in this case there's no
incentive actually there's a 14 billion
taxation charge so in other words you
might be very tempted just to put all
investment on hold and wait and see what
happens I said then we've got a two to
three billion uh portfolio of three
schemes been working on for seven or ten
years now my business started from
scratch and a bedroom in my house uh 25
years ago and we've come to this stage
now where we have eight or nine wind
farms operating so we've got a a an SME
business we're paying a lot of
corporation tax and taxes generally uh
benefits rates and the like in in the UK
and through big schemes lined up to for
two billion with which will support
hydrogen green hydrogen support green
data all the things that uh the chance
learning about 10 days ago said that he
has four or five uh sectors he wants to
see grow which will get the UK economy
out of recession one of which is digital
one is uh is green Industries the most
important green industry is green
electricity that's that's the the
building block for the whole green
sector have you crunched the numbers how
much is this ego going to affect your
company how much extra attacks will you
be paying well it's actually it's a tax
on income so the big issue for the for
the new the new schemes is quite
straightforward as you know inflation's
gone up uh you know two two pints of
milk is now 45 more uh really to wind
turbines of 45 50 more we can't buy them
at three Ukraine prices obviously uh as
you know mortgages all our mortgage
costs have gone up threefold so Finance
cost is a huge part of the uh of the
cost of a new equipment and new turbines
all that means that our prices our costs
have gone up but actually below uh sorry
above the 75 pound macaw level so
actually the 70 attacks on on income uh
it's not tax on profits and that's the
big difference so that will actually
hugely handle the numbers yeah it
depends on on how much uh we generate
also depends how much uh
um uh uh the actual the movie actually a
landsat at the end of course it'd be far
easier far more straightforward to
reform the structure of the electricity
market so that Renewables prices aren't
just linked to gas prices for example I
mean if do you kind of sense that the
government's just going for a tax grab
while it can for that reason absolutely
I mean there is a plan as you know
that's underway so that should happen
imminently so we can't quite understand
why there's tax grab for five years if
you look at the EU the level area is
only for the time period only for six
months the ten minutes to six months and
more importantly the actual 75 pound
level the the threshold is 120 pounds so
uh there's no taxation below 120. so
there's no it's quite clear that this is
there's no extraordinary profit from 75
pounds to 120 and it's it's very clear
and the cfd contracts the government
signed the last five or seven years over
100 pounds a megawatt so how can they be
extraordinary at 75 pounds doesn't make
sense uh Rod we're at the time I'm
afraid good to see you this morning
thank you
now it's well documented that there are
skills shortages across many Western
economies here in the UK for example
there are as many job vacancies as there
are unemployed people yet the latter are
often not equipped to fill the former
well today the U.S Network's giant Cisco
has announced a goal of training 10
million people in digital and cyber
security skills over the next decade
across the UK Europe the Middle East and
Africa joining me now is David Meads
he's chief executive at Cisco UK and
Ireland uh David welcome to you how much
is this going to cost roughly
well we're not really focusing on the
cost and we're focusing on the need so
the the Genesis of this is our Network
Academy program which we launched 25
years ago worldwide it's been active
across the globe in that time and in the
UK since its Inception we've had 350
students coming through that Academy
learning new skills security skills
cyber security skills data analytics and
and the Run rate of that is increasing
exponentially last year we had 60 000.
so this is a needs must it's not
something we're going to solve ourselves
as a standalone but I think we can make
a significant impact with those 10
million skills 10 million people being
impacted over the next 10 years but the
demand is there you know we know as
recently as Davos just two weeks ago in
I think they talked about that there's
going to be a shortage of about 85
million people with digital skills
across the globe in the next 10 years
what we're doing now and 2030 we know
from our own reports that we've
conducted with the center for economics
and business research that we could add
potentially another 168 billion pounds
to GDP in the UK in the next seven years
if we can address the skills Gap so it's
a necessity that we're focused on
driving
I'm an undergo training for
yeah and that's a great question because
it's quite varied if you look at those
60 000 students last year we saw 89 of
them actually go on into full-time
employment or into in fact further
studies so the nature of the academy is
we do from the very basic I.T essential
skills course which can be a matter of
days to actually industry certified high
demand skills that can take many months
so it's quite varied it's across a very
broad curriculum we have 300 active
academies in the UK today and it's
really interesting to see the
inclusivity as this as well Ian you know
we're able to take these academies into
places like
prisons for example we have academies
focusing on different neurodiversity
skills we work with the rnib around the
blind institutions so it's also
addressing a more inclusive approach to
how you get people into the into the
industry you've kind of preempted my
next question David which is going to be
are you focused primarily on school and
college students or is it older workers
perhaps seeking to to retrain and
reskill
or all of the above and I think in fact
increasingly we're going to see more of
the retraining and re-skilling we had a
really great example in partnership with
the Basco and Caledonian University in
Scotland in partnership with the
Scottish women in Tech late last year I
think and this was people who were
beyond the student years who were
looking to retrain specifically in cyber
security skills so great pilot for us
with some great successes so we're
looking to do Partnerships around the UK
and roll it out not just for the
generation coming into the workforce for
the first time but absolutely for
retraining and reskilling we're not
going to hit the number of skills that
we need to build into the industry to
support what economy is trying to do
from a digitization perspective without
looking at including all people from all
walks of life now you're speaking to us
today from Amsterdam we've already
started rolling this out in the
Netherlands and Italy what have you
learned so far
well we've learned that the demand is
exponential so that's great we've
learned that we can't do it alone we
have to do it in Partnership so
partnership with academic institutions
but also with private sector I actually
think it's probably one of the best
examples of a true public-private
partnership you know we're bringing the
best of Cisco our curriculum our
technology we're partnering with people
to give us scale and reach so the
lessons that we've learned from from uh
here in Netherlands which is the Cisco
live event that we're doing for the
first time in three years very exciting
for us to have 10 000 of our partners
and customers here in person we've
learned from what they're doing here
we've learned from what we're doing in
Italy but as I say we've been doing the
network Academy program in the UK for
over 20 years now so it's not new it's
just a case of how we ratchet up the
scale of this and get the reach and
partner with other technology companies
as well as Government to make sure that
we can really address this critical need
and do you think you'll be hiring people
who've come off these programs at the
end of it
well we have done today so you know it's
amazing some of the talent in fact I say
we have 10 000 of our customers and
partners here today many of those are
people who've actually alumni from the
network Academy program so whether it's
hiring uh Cisco our partners our
customers we know the demand is huge so
as I say the data point we had from last
year is 89 of those 60 000 students that
came through the UK academies went on to
full-time employment or indeed chose to
take on further certification so I don't
think there's any question that the
people who are committed to doing this
will actually find that there's a huge
demand for their skills okay David it's
good to catch up with you this morning
thanks for joining me
thanks again all the best
[Music]
well the oil price rallied yesterday
after the earthquake in Turkey raised
questions over exports from one of the
country's main terminals it's
Consolidated those games this morning as
you can see a barrel of Brent crude will
currently cost you 82.69 a barrel that
is up a little over two percent on the
session but on the equity markets last
night's falls on Wall Street were
followed by a mixed session overnight in
the Asia Pacific region Tokyo was flat
Hong Kong and Shanghai both rows but
there were reverses in Mumbai and in
Sydney well in Europe it was a largely
uh mixed session so far this morning you
go the ducks in Germany in negative
territory you feel the other Continental
European indices flatish or in positive
territory talking points this morning
include Siemens energy the shares in
Frankfurt down some four and a half
percent and that is on news that net
loss is more than doubled in the most
recent quarter well here in London the
ftse 100 is also in positive territory
yeah it's a half a point uh of one
percent uh higher right now 42 points to
the good nearly BP and show I've added
20 points to the index on their own to
offer those gains coming from BP and
show right now BP as you can see up by
just over four under a quarter percent
so far today outside the footsie Morgan
Advanced Materials the shares there are
down more than five percent five and a
quarter percent nearly now that's after
it warned that profits for the year will
be below expectations due to a recent
Cyber attack that it suffered while the
Ukrainian oil iron Miner for Expo the
shares they're down three percent that's
after the country's government throws
the bank accounts of its largest unit
among the gainers in the mid 250 today
auction Technology Group the shares are
up some four percent on positive broker
comment on the foreign exchange markets
well the main talking point is the
Australian dollar it's risen by some one
percent against the US dollar following
another interest rate rise from The
Reserve Bank of Australia the pound
meanwhile is down a tenth of one percent
against both the dollar and the Euro uh
joining me today is Ian Quigley head of
investment strategy at RBC Brewing
Dolphin Island in good to see you this
morning
um well it was Central Bank week last
week with the hikes from the third DCB
and the bank of England and here's the
Reserve Bank of Australia doing the same
yeah well over the past
um year and a bit obviously central
banks have been on a charge to raise
interest rates to bring interest rates
right back to where we were really
before the financial crisis so
um it's it's been dramatic
um higher Pace or faster pace of rates
than most would have envisaged and and
obviously that's had its impact on on
markets last year this year it's been
more benign now obviously we're in the
thick of uh earnings season right now BP
the showstopper of course today we've
had a lot of the big U.S tech companies
reporting last week what have you
divined so far from results that we've
had on both sides of the Atlantic
um yeah what they've been they've been
pretty mixed I think you're coming into
coming into the start of the Year
expectations were revised down uh
meaningfully enough and that that tends
to be the passion companies revised down
their earnings and then try to try to
then beat that beat that that lower and
that lower guidance
um thus far we again earnings have been
you know pretty lackluster flatish made
possibly even decline for the quarter
when you look at the U.S so you know
from an equity Market perspective that's
um yeah that that's clearly a negative
but that is said against the backdrop of
um what happened in 2022 where for a lot
of companies valuations came down a lot
um so valuations were down to a much
more reasonable levels and also and also
you've seen not understanding the fact
that central banks are continuing to
raise interest rates and bond yields
have come back a bit as well and some of
the inflationary pressures that we saw
last year are abating somewhat so it's
always a bit of a mixed picture or a
balance between what's happening with
earnings and what's happening in the
economy and then what's happening when
interest rates inflation effectively the
discount rate so at the moment at least
then earnings haven't been great but the
market has been strong enough
um because reflecting I think you know
part of the valuation reset we saw last
year well it's interesting I mean you
raised a good point though I mean I
think the s p and the US fell off by 20
last year but yet I was looking at some
research from Montreal Rivals now we're
making the point that actually U.S
equities still don't really recognize
good or represent good value compared
with some of the
peers in the UK and Germany in
particular where the overselling has
been has been far greater relative to
earnings
yeah yeah well U.S Equity markets always
look more expensive they're that they
are more higher valued
um and I think you can you can reconcile
that with your types of companies that
are in the US market particularly over
the last decade and with leadership from
the big tech companies and but generally
that there are companies that are in
higher return on Capital and higher than
return on Capital the higher valuation
should be all think all things being
equal
um there is the prospect I think you're
starting to see in European markets
actually have performed in the past two
quarters and indeed the UK last year and
that's more reflective of the
composition or the type of companies
that are in those markets
um you know you're you know I listened
earlier to the show and you're talking
about Renewables and investing and the
renewable supply chain for example
Europe is taking a bit of a leadership
in that area so again they're perhaps
areas where one could be a bit more
optimistic about uh European or UK
markets and from from a go forward
growth perspective but historically at
least the premium that the US has
warranties all down to the companies and
higher profitability of those companies
Ian what about the banks obviously we
start to hear from them over the next
few days I mean potentially this is an
area where there is there is going to be
real tangible earnings growth certainly
here in Europe
yeah net interest margins obviously
difference between the the the interest
rate they're paying on deposits and what
they're charging on on loans and has
really jumped up
um and and obviously for again you think
interest rates have basically gone are
essentially gone down for nearly 15
years since the financial crisis very
challenging backdrop for banks banks
have Nega much more Capital
um
um so we're not worried about kind of
systemic or loan crises like we might
have might have done in the past and
um there is the problem yeah as you say
I think that there are Tailwinds for
Bank earnings and provided the economy
doesn't go into recession of course
um and incrementally the new slow has
been better there I think everyone was
forecasting recession at the start of
the year and as you can see that's
slightly changing now some of the
investment banks are kind of going off
that a little bit so if the economy
expands and rates are higher that that
is a strong environment for banks now
again they have in part already
anticipated that so you always have to
ask the question looking at the
individual
um investment what's priced in
and what about geopolitics obviously
we're all talking about the earthquake
now but the big story over the weekend
was the shooting down of this Chinese
balloon has that impacted in any way the
way that you're looking at geopolitical
risks
I think reflecting not necess that
obviously is heightened and this this
this week but even if we look over the
past few years that tension competitive
tension between us and China has really
ratcheted up and that's not going away
we just need to learn to live with that
both from the investment perspective
from a political perspective from a kind
of everyday perspective if you like you
know these two these two um economic
Titans and competing with each other
um you can see that from you know us
essentially and asking their their um
the Dutch and the Japanese the stop
selling semiconductor equipment to China
um so that there is um that Rising
competitive tension it's going to be
there it's going to be there for the
next decade
um again what we saw over the this week
and shooting down the surveillance
balloon and again it's it's it's it's
another sign of that heightened tension
that's going to be around
um and you could look at it negatively
or positively I think it's definitely a
negative in the sense that the world has
benefited from greater globalization and
the the the
the disbursement of Supply chains over
the past decade and a lot of those China
benefited from that and the fact that
you know that companies are having to
reposition and think about that
strategically as negative for their
profitability the positive might also be
that you know there is a competitive
impulse to invest across perhaps
Renewables perhaps across semiconductors
as well so those some of those
Industries might benefit from China and
the us both investing more capitalism
right gotta leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
now the last year has seen a big uptick
in shared BuyBacks across Europe
European companies spent an estimated
350 billion dollars buying back their
shares last year while in the UK the
total was 55 and a half billion pounds
nearly half of which was accounted for
by BP and shell alone well it's a
practice that attracts a lot of
criticism not least for consuming
Capital that could be used for business
investment but my next guest argues that
the practice can make good sense with me
in the studio is Ian Lance he's co-fund
manager of the Temple Bar Investment
Trust Ian good to see you this morning
so when does a buyback make good sense
well we all think with any company
you've got four options when you when
you're thinking about Capital allocation
the first one is clearly investment
whether that's maintenance capex or
expansion capex uh the second one is
paying down debt and then after that
you've got basically two choices one is
Acquisitions and one is share BuyBacks
or dividends we always think that lots
of CEOs tend to be overly optimistic on
Acquisitions and they tend to
underestimate the impact that a share
buyback can have
um and the case study that we actually
used recently to look at this was was
next the figures on next are just
incredible if you've invested 100 pounds
in next in 2001 it would today be worth
1 750 pounds and yet its sales have only
grown at basically UK GDP throughout
that 20-year period about four percent
and and what is the difference between
that Top Line and the bottom line is
effectively share BuyBacks they retired
over half of their Equity throughout
that period but they only did it out to
free cash flows they didn't increase
their debt at all they didn't really
make any Acquisitions and they only
bought back the shares when they were
cheap so what we think that sort of
policy that next follows is is exactly
the model really that companies should
follow when they're thinking about share
BuyBacks yeah very very good point you
make that I mean a lot of companies do
hock themselves up to buy back their
shares but the other key point you made
there is they did it when the shares
were achieved and it's not really it's
it's an art rather than the science
isn't it known when your Shares are
under or overvalued it it is there's
there's a there was a famous quote by by
Warren Buffett who's always a good one
for a quote which is that if a if an
outstanding business with sound
financials find its finds itself with
its shares trading at a discount to
intrinsic value no policy other than the
share buyback can have more value and
and that's effectively how we think
about it when companies are trading very
very cheaply and you know frankly the
the management of the company should be
in the best position shouldn't they but
to be able to make that assessment then
then a share buyback should always be
the Benchmark that they're thinking
about the trouble is as I say a lot of
these BuyBacks do destroy value I'm
thinking for example of Home Retail
Group yes now called curries of course
spent hundreds of millions of pounds
buying back their own shares in in
around 2011 and it made no difference at
all I think yeah I'd agree with that and
I think also one can look at um some of
the big U.S technology companies who
basically issue shares to their
employees uh as part of the compensation
and then they basically use shareholders
as far as to buy back those shares so
that they don't get a dilution and you
know let's be honest one would argue
that those Shares are probably not very
cheap at the moment as well so that
actually would be a model where where we
don't like share BuyBacks and of course
share BuyBacks I mean they are they are
trotted at the numbers for Europe just
now I mean they are traditionally more
popular than in you in the US than they
are in Europe why is that why why do
European fund managers prefer dividends
I don't know to be honest with you it's
a cultural thing though um the the
income fund sector in the UK has you
know used to be an absolutely enormous
sector
um and it seems to be a cultural thing
that in UK and Europe we prefer our
dividends in in the US less so you know
they you're right they have relied more
on shared by historically Where Do We Go
From Here I mean we're in a rising
interest in rate environment for a lot
of companies presumably it's going to
make more sense for them to retire some
of their debt first then then start
buying back their Equity yeah we would
always say that you know if you're if
your balance sheet is overly stretched
then absolutely you should be paying
back down your debt but once you get to
the stage where uh you're you know
you're you you've done your investment
your balance sheet is in a good stage if
your Shares are still cheap then at that
point it does make sense to use
basically free or excess cash flow to
buy back your stock so I'm going to be
very cruel in and put you on the spots
here I mean if you look at BP's results
today for example I mean clearly they
have been buying but their stock their
debts at uh its lowest level for a
decade where do they go from here would
you prefer to see more buy-backs or
would you prefer to see them I mean
they've raised capex as well that you
can do it all when you've got record
profits I guess you absolutely can and
it's a balancing act with them isn't it
so they are up and I've said this
morning that they're up in their capital
expenditure both in the Renewables area
and in the more traditional areas
they've increased their dividend by 10
10 but they've also said they are going
to increase their share BuyBacks as well
beefy shares trading on a price earnings
ratio five at the moment so you've got
you know you've got a strong balance
sheet you're throwing off cash buying
back your shares on a P5 makes makes a
lot of sense yes even even a dimwit like
me can see that yeah good to catch up
here again thank you thank you very much
[Music]
time for a look now uh this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with the
earthquake in turkey and Syria but it
also reports on its Front Page News at
the UK Treasury and Bank of England are
designing a digital pouch that could
Supply banknotes by the end of this
decade the Ft leads its companies
section meanwhile with news at the
Rothschild family is planning to take
its Investment Bank Rothschild and
co-private in a move that values one of
the most renowned names in global
Finance at 3.7 billion euros well the
times leads its business pages with a
warning from Nissan that high energy
costs and an eroding automotive supply
chain in Britain are making its plant at
Sunderland which is the UK's largest car
flat uncompetitive the paper also
reports on its business front page
comments from Elon Musk yesterday that
Twitter is on course to come out of the
red following thousands of job Cuts
meanwhile The Daily Telegraph leads with
a warning to the prime minister of the
need to come up with a rival to
President Joe Biden's massive program of
subsidies that came in a letter to Rishi
sunak from the chief executive of Virgin
Atlantic Coots Heathrow Airport and
rolls-royce's nuclear power project the
paper also reports that strike-breaking
rail managers were paid 50 pounds an
hour on top of their salaries to work on
the front line during walkouts over
Christmas while joining me this morning
and Simon English he's an actual editor
at the evening standard Simon welcome to
you let's start with this Twitter story
because that really is quite uh a
statement from Elon Musk
yeah so it's amazing if true
um he isn't giving us much detail but at
this point it's just Elon says
um but there's uh it's amazing if he has
done it that quickly so when he bought
it he paid forcible billion dollars
almost by mistake it felt right you know
he got himself into this deal he didn't
really want to do any overpaid for it
and everybody thought it would be a
disaster and if already he's making
money
um it is quite something I mean there's
there's two Elon Musk isn't there
there's the there's the wacky guy who
just wants to be famous and just says
things for the fun of it
um and then there's the other one we
just seemed to be seriously good at
running businesses
well maybe I mean it's a good point you
raise him and he also said yesterday I
mean he kind of admitted it had taken
his eye off the ball with Tesla and
SpaceX but I mean if he can turn Twitter
into a profit very very quickly I mean
it's going to be astonishing isn't I
mean maybe he is a much better manager
than people giving credit for
I've seen other CEOs start to uh admit
that you know more stayed sort of people
so actually uh maybe maybe we should be
running our businesses the way he runs
his so he just does things very very
quickly doesn't he so um he cut staff
from over seven thousand to just over
two thousand very quickly you think
normally a normal business would would
collapse with that sudden cutting style
Twitter signals to have got better maybe
he is as good as he says he is
now what about this digital pound story
covered widely in the Ft among others I
mean what do we make of this
well I don't understand it and I don't
think any of the people involved
understand it either so so it's it's
been kicked around for a while this idea
that the bank of England could have a
digital panel
didn't already exist you know most
pounds are digital
um you know if you bought me a football
ticket for 50 Quid and I send you 50
Quid back no 50 pound note was earned
anywhere involved in that transaction it
was all digital
um and um I have not to see anybody at
the treasury or the bank really
explained why it wants to do this so
they had Andrew used economics
Etc he was on the radio this morning
talking about it and if you made a fair
case for why they want to do it I
couldn't I couldn't fathom it it seems
to me to be it's a defensive
I think so the bank of England is
worried that if it doesn't come up with
something like this someone else will do
um and someone else might come up with a
system we're all very to use aside from
the digital pounds that we use all the
time and that might undermine the
banking system through an effect but it
feels like they're coming at it from
that point of view I haven't actually
heard anyone explain why it's good
yeah the bank of England used to do
teachings for us didn't they in the old
days US Financial hacks maybe they need
to turn on this I think they could do
with one yeah
now what about uh sport we have this big
announcement yesterday from the Premier
League charging Man City with financial
uh breaking the financial rules
essentially I mean if you think there
are wider ramifications for this
well they probably are aren't they I
mean if you're not a Manchester City fan
it's delicious and you think they've got
it coming
um but there's another uh uh teams out
there that may have spent a lot of money
too
um my team Nottingham forests have spent
about 160 million uh since the summer I
actually don't particularly want the
authorities to look too closely at that
I can't believe that it's just
Manchester City that have been breach of
the rules here it seems unlike your
stuff now well quite I mean it makes you
wonder for a start what how Chelsea
managed to avoid such scrutiny all the
years when Abramovich was spraying
billions around
uh well exactly and how far back are we
going to go
um we could go back a long way it seems
to me and um maybe if man city looked
like uh they are going to be in breached
maybe they'll start insisting on that
maybe they'll start saying well what
about that bill 20 years ago what about
that because 30 years ago that was no
way that was in line with the rules
um it could go on for a long time list
all right Simon got to leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
well we were talking about Manchester
City there and few UK cities have been
regenerated during the past 40 years as
effectively as Manchester from the late
1970s when it was mired in
post-industrial Decline Manchester is
now one of the fastest growing Urban
regions in Europe while it's football
teams its music and its universities
have made it a key Center for sport
culture and scientific innovation well
that transformation has now been
chronicled in a new book Manchester
unspun the author is the journalist
turned Communications professional Andy
Spinoza who joins me now from Manchester
Andy welcome to you I mean for those who
want us intimately connected with
Manchester as you are just sum up the
sort of transformation that's taken
place
well one measure would be in 1980 when I
arrived in the city uh barely 500 people
lived in the city center
um most of those were caretakers looking
after business premises uh today in that
same city center area you have 75 000
people
um a lot of lot living in um Towers over
20 stories and a lot of young people so
the Manchester Salford interlocking City
centers is one of the fastest growing
um urban areas in in the country with
also one of the youngest populations by
age so
um you've got tech companies moving here
in fact booking.com open new Offices
here and um office take-up is back to
pre-pandemic levels so
um and the matches having
um a pretty good near recession uh in in
um which you know is probably
underappreciated I would say uh in
London
yeah Fair Point fair point I mean your
starting point in the book which I
thought was really interesting is that
it was the Hacienda nightclub that
kicked off a lot of this transformation
yeah I mean that is the broad Trust of
the book it sounds kind of preposterous
could a city's Renaissance be
um you know be be laid at the at the uh
could the credit be given for a
nightclub uh and a music label Factory
records and I would you know argue that
the Hacienda in 1982 when it opened gave
the kiss of life to a dying City Center
um and it it it gave a Fascination I
think to Manchester because while it was
most of celebrating yourself
um there also was the design values of
the club and and Factory records which
made it interesting internationally gave
it a Charisma
um that I think still existed today
today you'll you'll find a lot of CEOs
in my kind of age and maybe your kind of
age I know you're a bit younger than me
but um who
um still talk about uh fashion records
the Hacienda as um as key parts of
they're growing up and that's given
Manchester I think an international
appeal it also encouraged property
developers to come into the center
um to set up bars restaurants nightclubs
Small Beginnings but that set off a
chain reaction that leads to this sort
of dynamic Center that we that we have
today absolutely now you mentioned the
property of course Central to all this I
think probably you give him credit for
being the most important individual
figure in all of this is so Howard
Bernstein who was the chief executive of
Manchester City Council
indeed and I think um you know he is uh
he was seen for instance by George
Osborne as the the star of uh of the
nation's Urban regeneration
um renowned for being a deal to her and
renowned as well for his partnership um
with Sir Richard lease the political
leader of the council as a as a pair
they
um effectively ran Manchester he could
say LED Manchester for over three
decades both have now stepped down from
um from their Council roles but I would
argue that the you know the processes
and the practices that they
um they honed while in uh in in power
they those those been deeply embedded in
the city council and you know there is
no letter you know during the pandemic
construction here really continue to
pace and um we have 55 Towers now over
um 20 stories in The Wider Central
Manchester area there's a pipeline
um which means that by 2030 that number
would have doubled and so you can see
the kind of scale of demand and a lot of
a lot of that is due to this very strong
Civic leadership
it is what's really interesting though
is that you make the point in the book
Richard lease was obviously a labor
politician but was prepared to cross the
political divide and and cooperate with
George Osborne whereas down the East
lancx Road in in Liverpool basically
they set themselves up in opposition to
Westminster
yeah there's a bit of a history lesson
here so in the in the mid 80s Manchester
was faced with do we go down the route
that Liverpool took which is outright
confrontation with the conservative
government
um in the
um summer of I think
1987 there was a U-turn
um
uh then lead a grand Stringer and helped
by Sir Richard by Richard Lee's uh
turned the council's policy around uh
wrote to conservative government we want
to work with you and that led to our
whole range of
um partnership with
um parties are both political colors
labor and conservative over the last 30
years and I think what my book tries to
get across perhaps to a lot of people
surprised is that Manchester's labor
Council has got a better shake from the
Tories over the last 30 years than from
labor governments and um you know I
hopefully hopefully that was an
interesting informative read for people
yeah absolutely now you make it make the
point that uh we just have that uh
Manchester's had a pretty good near
recession building work continuing a
pace what are the potential obstacles to
Manchester retaining its economic
dominance of the north of England
well I think that um it's been you know
academics and and uh it think tanks
point to productivity
um probably lagging behind well
certainly a lot of the north Lakme
hiding productivity but um we don't have
the productive productivity levels that
are that anywhere near London
um I think from that aspect you know the
um the new rise in Tech sector jobs uh I
think we're approaching a hundred
thousand jobs in Greater Manchester in
the sort of digital Tech sector and that
might help to improve things but there's
also the
concern to disquiet among I suppose
people like me who have been here for
over 40 years that some of that unique
Charisma and character that Manchester
had that so attracted
um you know many people here to put down
routes and to do interesting creative
things that that um that may be being
erased by
um you know by large companies by tall
towers by the very
regeneration process that the city so
desired so there's an interesting
challenge there to keep the uniqueness
of Manchester alive
you talked just now about the cultural
heritage of Manchester does it do enough
to celebrate its scientific I mean this
is all for all where Rutherford split
the atom it's where Alan Turing worked
on the first computers
I think those letters have been learned
um you know the fact we found that Tony
Wilson always said that those um those
advances and discoveries you've just
mentioned all happened in one street and
if that would have been in America it
would have been a great big theme park
there um or Museum celebrating it but I
think you've got
um The Innovation Factory at the
University of Manchester which is doing
a great job with with spin outs uh you
do have life sciences
um very strong
spin out
um scene here and I think the I think
matches University and the other
universities that there are several in
the city
um
are are on the right track in terms of
commercializing
um the the research that comes out of
them and also I mean if if one talks
culturally I mean you've mentioned
Factory records and Joy Division but
also you know this was a city where the
suffragettes really uh built their
reputation and more recently you know
it's probably where the sort of Gay
Pride movement has had it it's sort of
strongest advocacy
yeah I think that Manchester's got this
almost schizophrenic side you know
you've got the the rampaging commercial
mentality of Victorian era but Yorkshire
had the radical
um tradition uh as you say of uh of
suffragettes and trade unions and I
think this the two two size
um always intention sparks flying uh
it's kind of the The Perennial
um attractions of the city I think
through Outsiders that um whatever goes
on here we don't have the great
institutions of State uh that London has
but you know whether it's football
culture or politics there's all there's
there's always some interesting uh
controversy or um or debate going on
there really is Andy it's a fantastic
book and it's lovely to see you this
morning thanks very much for joining me
just before I go a bit of breaking news
uh Sky News Now understands that can be
badanok the international trade
secretary is indeed to become the
business and trade secretary will have
more on that throughout the morning here
on Sky News there's much more on the Sky
News Mobile app and on the website with
reporting video content and Analysis
from our business team I hope you've
enjoyed watching this uh on the digital
platforms today hopefully we'll be back
on the Telly tomorrow but you never know
the point is you can watch us now
wherever you are in the world back
tomorrow at 10 o'clock hope to see you
then thanks for joining me today Julia
foreign
[Music]